[Musique]
pour moi les deux pins question d'années
de
ressentir comme ça and it should je ne
devais pas de perruque et comptera donc
ma fille devenue annuelle qui est
confuse qui est venu à mézos
tendu le ramener ça n'a pas été dans cet
agrément
et me soutiennent beaucoup
et la maison de ma voiture super mais ça
te va bien
total à fond de ta tête les barmans et
puis c'est la ronde ya beaucoup de
filles qui sera mieux à même de montrer
des photos et puis finalement ou ceux
des journaux pour pas mal mais
là ça va
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai encore sans
titre en jeu j'ai toujours continué
marie tête map eric mais j'ai pas encore
franchi ce pas de sortir comme un
symbole
juncker
[Musique]